it is the official discussion of the toc
community I just to share some of my
thoughts in the next 15 minutes about
multiple hypotheses testing and this is
the sum looked into it with some of the
people here and otherwise based on some
intriguing similarity that Cynthia
pointed out between the error
accumulation in multiple hypotheses
testing and the way a privacy errors can
accumulate when you're querying a
database multiple times but the Duke
show saw a beautiful that we allowed
ourselves to forget at times the
original motivation but even with this
kind of Fame very superficial reading
into this literature I'm certainly not
an expert so what these 15 minutes are
going to be about I suppose that you are
not interested in reading my dear diary
entries about reading your papers
especially here you have but the point I
guess of this program in this workshop
the observation is that more and more
statistics and CSR kind of overlapping
and therefore it could be useful to go
over some of the role thoughts and even
with understandings of a computer
scientist reading this literature I
should say that before while preparing
it I was afraid of two things one is to
kind of border the substitutions by
raising things that they already
discussed and settled in a statistics
kindergarten and the other thing was to
be just wrong I want to claim all of
this can be embarrassing for me but I
think it can still a even in this case
can still a promote science and anyway I
think that compared to the arrows that
your elbows pointing in textbooks and
statistics like I may not do worse and
again I won't give references because of
the time and also not to get them wrong
but in our defense of
is that we started 20 years behind and
by now we're raising ideas that are only
two years late so if you want to
understand what or guess what you're
going to publish in a year ask us in
three years we'll know and the plan is
to discuss can these three kind of ideas
there are mainly about what are the
definitions of our kind of frameworks
that are natural to computer scientists
and perhaps could help merge some of
these research fields and I mean the top
was so clear and neutral it's needed but
let me just do a very quick recap of one
slide so we have our M nyla potus's and
we're putting our M best scientists on
the job trying to test each one of them
out of each there are the trueness or M
not we're getting all of the p-values
for each one of these tests and now we
want to select one that we think are
significant discoveries these are the
ones that we love so naturally we call
them the rejected one because we are it
may it doesn't make sense that the first
reading but it makes a lot of sense we
are rejecting the null hypothesis and
this is the only thing we can do and now
just the parameters we have our which is
the number of rejected among them we
have V that are rejected although they
are true nails which are detect one
errors that we want to bound and we have
these two measures that we heard about
the familywize error which is just a
probability of making any of any type
one there and the other one is what the
fraction the expected fraction of arrows
were making so think about it as V over
R but if we didn't find anything we say
that the rate of arrows d0 okay so I'll
start with the most I mean banana think
a observation for for this decision and
this is about parameters so for computer
scientists like myself a field
I'm missing some parameters and against
the reason is that I was raised on this
a valiant a pack learning where we want
to learn and I potus's an approximation
age to some function f and our measure
is that we want the probability of our
learning algorithm that this is an
epsilon approximation of what we're
going to learn the disability with or
that it will be that you are not I mean
more than epsilon will be smaller than
Delta so i can i can think about this as
delta being the statistical significance
of my finding an epsilon being the
material significant significance and at
least in learning theory i think that
separating these two parameters was
extremely important and was responsible
to solve the most interesting research
done for example boosting the way of
amplifying one of these parameters now p
values combine these two kinds of errors
and then and and of course the disk
literature is well aware of it and we
saw some of it in the second parts of
the earth stop hey but i'll just say
that I mean a natural definition for me
would kind of separate these discounters
in perhaps have PSP what's the
probability of getting this result if
the null hypothesis is an epsilon
approximation of the epsilon 2 and
similarly for the SDR one natural kind
of question is should we talk about
expectation or talk about the
probability that the first discovery
rate is larger than some something and
again the literature deals with it I'm
just pointing out what's the natural
definitions for for a computer scientist
okay so that was one point
data point and start with this kind of
criticism of SDR that comes with there
with this example so let's think about a
situation was with probability off we
don't find anything that will probably
have we do find and we do reject
something some vertices and in this case
they expected a ratio of our arrows is
to alpha in this case the FDR with the
alpha and the criticism says okay but
the interesting case is the case when we
do find something and therefore in this
case we have a narrative which is a bit
larger than than we hoped for so once
you think of the FDR is the app for your
a probability that when we look at one
of the rejected hypothesis it will be a
truly null and and the question is can
we come up with a posterior guarantee so
say given that our is larger than zero
and this is exactly what story did by
suggesting the positive FDR which is
expected of the expected fraction
Pharaoh's conditional are being larger
than zero hey but I mean we can suggest
a similar criticism of the fear dr as as
for this dr because and here is another
story so in this story i would probably
have we have just one finding and in
this case the finding is correct always
with probability half we have 100
findings and then in this case the ratio
is to alpha again at the FDR or and the
PFD are will be alpha but the really
interesting case is the one when we have
a lot of findings this is the case what
we're going to invest a lot of money
later in looking into all this finding
and again this is bit larger than the
resident that we were shooting for now
as far as i understand it in the beijing
setting work EG potus's
support built-in island with some
probability and first the null is false
then the PFD are does give a good
interpretation in terms of posterior
probabilities and at the question I'm
going to ask is can we have to sing a
similar situation and when we don't want
to adopt the Beijing perspective but
want to look at it from a frequentist
perspective so can we for example ask
for the expectation of the probability
of the fraction of errors the rate of
errors conditional all all that we've
seen p 1 up 2 p.m. and the answer will
be the No and not is certainly not in
the setting of the original a phenomenal
third and study where we have s which is
the set of true knowledge and for them
the pies are even with our aiid and
uniform but we're making no assumptions
of the other pies so in this setting
condition on the p1 up to p.m. there is
not a lot of expectation that's left or
probability distribution is left so now
the question is what is the right
definition for this up a story a kind of
definition and then again come to
something that you're always talking
about you stop and but from the
perspective a perspective of kind of
testing poverty testing which is
thinking about it as a mixture of
distributions and let's concentrate and
join the industry that they are was
talking about of estimating am NOT and
instead of just completely finding and
which are the true nails in which are
are not with us but just estimating the
number of tools and this does improve
the nominee of procedure by itself so in
the setting of independence what we had
what we're seeing is M naught P is the
only
form in 01 and a limited balloon from 01
and we're seeing some other p is that
are arbitrary so so we have this a
sequence of specific observation that we
have seen I'm not making any assumptions
like in the beginning of berk setting
I'm not making any assumption of what
they are but I want to define a
distribution x which is uniform on these
values pj on this specific observation
and now what I have here is that the
sequence p 1 up 2 p.m. that I'm seeing
of p-values around a random element in
this sequence is a mixer is distributed
according to a mixture of two
probability distributions one is X and
the other one is the uniform
distribution on 01 and the way it's are
dependent specifically on am not so by
the way if it's not independent we can
do the similar trick with respect to the
uniform distribution so now that the the
problem is very similar to something
that both statisticians and computer
scientists have been looking it which is
to kind of separate or just estimate the
weight of two a mixture in a mixture of
two distributions and so we would like a
an estimator m naught hat says that
first expectation of em not add will be
larger than M naught therefore we can
use it for example in the beginning of
the procedure and we want it to be the
case that as X gets far from uniform the
estimation gets close to what it should
be and that's naturally I mean the P is
for the not for the non Eternals is
arbitrary
they can be uniform so if they are a
uniform nobody can expect us to estimate
am NOT well but if there are different
if there is a difference between true
nas and non through nails we want to get
a benefit out of it and now this is a
framer because now we can ask what does
it mean that X is far from uniform and
you can have various kind of answers can
be different in earthmover the instance
in some moments and given the answer
we're giving here so some assumption on
what interest does we'll get a different
way probably estimate am NOT this is
kind of freaking each one of these
suggestions would give us an estimator
that can be it's always correct and can
be useful depending on our input okay
and let me go to the third and last
point I'll turn to making the point is
that the picture is kind of changing and
it was never all in this case of kind of
these M scientists coming up with any
policies that they want to test them and
doing this in general but it's more and
more and a situation where we have a
procedure an algorithm a computation
that is generating the hypothesis and
testing it with in kind of a subroutine
of an algorithm of a computation and now
the errors of individual and potus's
testing is not what we care about what
you care about is the overall error of
the procedure and perhaps it is the next
stage we can ask not what's the
procedure and was there all right of the
procedure but what's the error rate that
the task requires and similar to asking
about the efficiency of an algorithm
process the efficiency of a
computational problem I want to say that
you can definitely describe boss
family-wide error rate and FDR as
special cases of this more general
definition and let me conclude with
asking about adaptive choices of
hypothesis can we use this the fact that
we have some control about the X potus's
that we're generating to get things that
are better and indeed we already sold
sound design in the top and filtering
where you're doing two rounds or more of
filtering your hypothesis these three
kind of approach to testing and pairwise
comparisons model selection various
cases were that the participating is
just a min to an end so this is not new
but this framework of suggesting
controlling the procedure error could be
a useful one and definitely useful on by
the connection it's making with machine
learning that does want to think about
things this way and there is a a
connection to differential privacy which
was our original motivation and I just
said it in interfacial privacy error
accumulation can be better than linear
and the question is can we adopt it into
the multiple testing and this could be
the case when the hypotheses are related
finally adaptive choices of hypotheses
of its dangers we can adaptively go into
especially whenever you be using data
can adaptively go into the anome
allottees of our data and I think CSS
something to offer every disrespected
well then conclusion there are many
connection points between multiple
hypothesis testing and theory of
computing both machine learning
differential privacy property testing
and the perspective may be a bit
different but bridging this gap could be
useful and I want to end with this idea
of this question of what can be done
with this notion of controlling the
procedure right rather than the
the error in that possesses testing does
it thank you so any follow up with your
georgia agreed to somebody i wonder
whether the air weights that i didn't
discuss give you some where you talk
about the assuring that the probability
that they be over our will not be bigger
than one- will not be bigger than
epsilon to keep this at the probability
of our fight will not give the an
interest in connection to what you
wanted in terms of the two error right
right this definitely maybe there might
be interesting to school this is just
more of a comment or connection so this
adapter hypothesis testing motivates a
field of active learning which is a line
of research in machine learning and i
think Dina balkan is going to talk about
that tomorrow and I think petaling my
feet they have some more recent work
connecting that to privacy I was just
gonna ask if I mean one way to state
what you're after if I understood at
least one of the things crafting and
just to correctly basically you want now
effectively a confidence interval on
this the over are right if I you know
that would be one way to when I high up
with a list of hypotheses and I output
also some post talk you know estimation
how good I am NOT obviously that that's
going to require it might require extra
assumptions or more information about I
actually deleted I'm not even sure mean
the literature does give them some cases
margin margin of error I'm not saying
that the literature doesn't deal with it
I'm as only asking and kind of what's
the natural basic definition to deal
with I mean the list I mean the
literature specifically talks at times
about margins of errors so it's less I
mean my point of view in all of these is
less about and I mean completely new
ideas but asking what's the right
definition to work with what's the right
failure to work with
Oh
1 commented out mentioned is that you're
worrying about the distribution given
the p-values and in fact the original
theorem has a few condition of the p
values that are knobs that are do not
come from the laws that are normal you
condition whatever values there when you
still have the fourth discovery
proportionate expectation and so it is
it seems strange but if you just all of
your p values or uniform 01 and you just
cover them and say this half are false
and this half of Y then you do the folks
from it and use the big procedure you
will get the false discover it over half
times Q so in that sense moving from
this situation out is a matter of power
more than more than fdr's own on
discovering a false not discover rated
this kind of ideas may be useful for
this for this motion okay let's go
I